tenemos aquí 30 x cuadrada más 11 x
más cuadrada y lo que queremos hacer en
este vídeo es usar todo lo que ya
sabemos acerca de factorización de
expresiones cuadráticas para factorizar
esta expresión ok entonces yo te
recomiendo que le pongas pausa este
vídeo y trates de resolverlo tú solito
por tu cuenta a ver si te pareció
suficientemente sencillo pero bueno si
te ha tórax mucho entonces regresa y
termina de ver este vídeo ok entonces
tenemos esta expresión y el truco aquí
es reacomodar estos términos vamos a
poner por aquí de cuadrada
11 x más 30 x cuadrada y la razón por la
que los acomodo de esta forma es porque
pues aunque aquí tenemos una expresión
en términos de x y pues en términos de x
esto es una cuadrática porque aquí estas
dos cosas son un coeficiente de x y esta
cosa no depende de x en lo más mínimo
entonces esto se convierte en una cuadra
ticket en términos de x la forma en la
que podemos pensar de esta forma es que
si nosotros ya supiéramos exactamente
cuánto vale osea si yo fuera un número
fijo entonces esto en realidad sí sería
tal cual una expresión cuadrática sobre
la variable x ahora lo real como ve así
porque esta expresión cuadrática tiene
este coeficiente al lado de la x
cuadrada y esos pues si hay una forma de
factorizar estas expresiones cuadráticas
pero todavía no lo hemos visto y es un
poquito más complicado
no mucho pero ligeramente sin embargo si
reacomodamos los términos y empezamos a
considerar la variable
entonces lo que tenemos es una expresión
cuadrática cuyo coeficiente al lado de
la de cuadrada es un 1 y esa si las
podemos resolver así rapidísimo ahora
esta es una expresión cuadrática en
términos de la variable y porque este
último término no depende para nada de
la variable y y aquí tenemos otro
coeficiente que multiplica a la ye
solita y pues aquí está la de cuadrada
entonces si sabemos exactamente cuánto
vale x esto es una expresión cuadrática
sobre la variable
común y corriente vamos a tratar de
resolverlo de la forma en la que hemos
estado haciéndolo últimamente en los
últimos vídeos ok
estamos buscando dos términos que cuando
los multiplicamos
nos da 30 x cuadrada pero que cuando lo
sumamos
nos da 11 x entonces como vamos a atacar
ese problema de encontrar esas dos
expresiones pues podemos empezar por
pensar en dos números que si los
multiplicamos nos queda 30 pero que si
los sumamos nos queda 11 entonces eso
creo que ya lo hemos hecho sino en uno
de los vídeos en alguno de los
ejercicios y pues podemos pensar en 5
con 6 5 por 6 nos da 35 más 6 nos da 11
y bueno como llegamos a 5 y 6 pues es
simplemente una cuestión de agarrar
todos los pares de números que si los
multiplicamos nos da 30 y ver cuál de
esos pares si los sumamos nos queda 11
ok se puede resolver con prueba y error
y bueno ya que tenemos cuáles números y
los multiplicamos nos da 30 y si los
sumamos nos da 11 ahora queremos que si
los multiplicamos nos de 30 x cuadrada
y si lo sumamos nos de 11 x entonces
pues yo propongo que pongamos una equis
aquí y otra equis por acá y entonces si
los multiplicamos nos queda 30 x
cuadrada y si los sumamos 5x + 6x pues
si nos queda 11 x entonces lo que hemos
visto de las ecuaciones cuadráticas nos
dice que esta expresión es exactamente
igual
y más 5x por qué más
x y bueno ahorita puedes agarrar y
desarrollar esta multiplicación de
binomios y vas a ver que nos queda
exactamente 30 x cuadrado más 11 x más
de cuadrada pero el chiste es que ya
terminamos de factorizar esta expresión
utilizando únicamente lo que ya sabíamos
hasta este momento